[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash how you doing
before we get started let me let me tell
you where I will be in the next few
weeks
des Moines Sioux Falls and Fargo
Edmonton and also Victoria BC I'll be in
Memphis Tennessee June 27th Chattanooga
Tennessee June 28th and Knoxville
Tennessee you guessed it June 29th so
that's where I'll be babies on the
follow-the-leader tour get your tickets
at Chris D'Elia calm if you want to be a
specific a specific [ __ ] go to Chris
D'Elia comm slash the [ __ ] tour just
I don't know just go to Chris Lee comm
whatever it's all good but yeah this is
the this is episode one one eight and we
are live on my app you can get the the
video the first ten minutes of the video
of the podcast video wise on my app and
you can get it live [ __ ] it we'll do it
live and so that's awesome that you can
do that so go to download my app if
you'd like and if not it's all good um
but softie please please father do it I
[ __ ] did you see the thing that 50
cent did uh when he talked to that
producer Randall Emmet about he needs
his money and [ __ ] he was like yo
Randall Emmet give me my money by
[ __ ] Monday and then posted the text
exchange that Randall Emmet sent to 250
and dude he wrote he wrote back please
I'm going to the hospital for stress
like please stop 50 please no more he
wrote 50 instead of 50
how do you get your autocorrect to make
fifty fifty to fifty please dude when I
saw fifty I fell out see ya when I saw
$59 and then was like aw [ __ ] I don't
even give a [ __ ] I said fifty what ever
think about how stressed he was I'm
sorry again I really and I said I'm
sorry father I said I'm sorry father
oh my god so disrespectful that he still
got the [ __ ] 50 in there you know I
know I owe you a million dollars but
still your father
that's awesome I call him father cents
from now on 50 cents how wide is it I
said this on his pockets before but when
when more 50 cent came out and people
and white people used to be like fitty
cent god I wanted to [ __ ] punch
everybody who did that I wanted to do
the Batman punch where'd you [ __ ]
just go like this
dude whenever I would do my my brother
and I would talk about would do whenever
we talk about this is my dad like how a
punch sound would go and my dad would
always be like he would be like he would
try to do the sound effect and he would
always go hear doors go
and it's we would be like note that it's
and he would say oh he would go cope and
we would be like dad go and it would be
like course and then we'd be like okay
and then and you would be like we're
gonna just put it together and he would
go oh hey Sid dad please father so so he
so so yeah so I would do that I'm also
his dad my grandpa BAM everyone called
him cuz he was skinny like a bamboo up
until he got older but he was he
couldn't say H he would say H and my dad
would tell him it's try it it's eight
and you would be like hate she'd be like
to go a and he would go a you go shhh
and put it together H and that's karma
coming back around
now you go ko pitched I wonder where my
[ __ ] will be when I get older you know
what I mean what I do know is Kay nobody
tell me nothing you can't tell me
nothing little nods love 50 dude I'm
gonna be a rapper and be a little fifty
um by the way people are saying on my
app
50 it's not fifty it's fifty fo f that's
what that's that's the real [ __ ]
so let's see well what the [ __ ] been
going on dude I was it I was it uh oh I
did my shows in Oakland and Las Vegas
and then I flew all the way over to
Connecticut mm-hmm
when I was in Oakland dude when I was in
Oakland
first of all Seok 'land dude when I was
in Oakland for some reason I always
thought that Oakland had so much
graffiti in it I don't know why I
thought that I don't know if I saw a
movie or some [ __ ] or whatever but when
I got to Oakland everything was graffiti
and I was like I was right how did I
know that I've never been to Oakland got
to Oakland saw everything that was
spray-painted in bubbly letters Oakland
is so gangster dude like the stuff like
the side of Starbucks has [ __ ]
colorful popping off letters and [ __ ]
everything is graffitied you park your
car you walk into a place you come back
your car got graffiti on the side of it
and she says [ __ ] Oakland zone with
the Z Oakland zone Oakland's own yeah
dude
so so I went to Oakland there was so
much graffiti did the show I was with my
I was with two openers hmm the show is
pretty good the theaters [ __ ] goddamn
beautiful dude I don't even know why
that theater is shown
it's so crazy when a theater sona that
theater so nice it revamped oakland
there were like two blocks of oakland
that were like really nice and then the
rest of it you can get [ __ ] so killed
two blocks oakland beautiful the rest of
the blocks oakland you can get so killed
but so no but oakland is like apparently
the the place that they're like
gentrifying next outside it's like the
Silver Lake of San Francisco but so I
did the show got back it's really not
much to do in Oakland at least on a
[ __ ] Thursday night and so I so we
went back that we tried to get a
delivery for food from a nap and we got
it and waited for an hour which is
sometimes how long it takes understood
maybe Thursday night in Oakland is a
busy time for the food app service uh
called me fifty minutes in and said hey
sorry but the pizza place to try to get
pizza from ran out of dough fifty
minutes at fifty minutes in dude now my
level of rage through the roof call me
in the beginning
you got them pizza place this way we
[ __ ] diminished that the fiery rage
okay breathe through it was starving
still thought you know what fifty
minutes of my life not a big deal so
I'll [ __ ] order another one so ordered
another one from a different pizza place
that looked way worse but it doesn't
matter because I was just hungry at this
point I need to fill my belly right
ordered another [ __ ] place from a
pizza place no [ __ ] called me fifty
minutes later and the place ran out of
[ __ ] ran out of dough okay so now
that's two different pizza places that
ran out of dough now hey this is where I
say pizza place don't
run out of dough because that's how you
make pizza and if you don't have dough
then you don't have pizza and if you
don't have pizza you're not a pizza
place and if you're not a pizza place
you're not making money any other way
because your job is having a pizza place
and you need a job in this world okay so
I ordered from a third pizza place no
[ __ ]
I waited an hour they [ __ ] called I
called them and they said and this is no
[ __ ] we ran out of dough this is the
third pizza place in Oakland that ran
out of dough now this is three hours in
no dough anywhere in Oakland I'm trying
to get pizza I can't get it so now mmm
pissed I can't be sorry I'm so you know
when you're hungry everything is more
angry and so I'm sorry angry
now it's 3:00 a.m. all right now I say
[ __ ] these goddamn pizza places in
Oakland all right I'm gonna go to a
diner I go on the app I look for a diner
the diner closes at 4:00 I look at how
long it's gonna take me to get this
[ __ ] goddamn turkey sandwich or
whatever the hell I get it's gonna take
35 minutes okay so now I order the [ __ ]
from the app it says it's coming in 35
40 50 minutes whatever the [ __ ] it is I
call the diner I say hey diner this is
what happened I tried to get a thing
from three different pizza places and it
couldn't come through now I know you
come up you close at 4:00 cuz I checked
online covered my bases my babies so I
looked so I called them and I said I
just want to make sure that if the
postmates sky is late and gets there at
like 405 or whatever the [ __ ] that
you're not gonna not let them in okay
and and whatever and the guy says oh no
we make we make the food there's no
problem we make the food I said okay
we're gonna make it right now they make
it right now okay
the the restaurant at 4 a.m.
cancels my Kansas my order okay I've
stayed up for hours to try and eat I
should have slept stayed up because I so
hungry alright didn't now I'm pissed cuz
I had to watch the [ __ ] purge movie
during the whole thing the orange the
origin story of the purge whatever the
[ __ ] I'm a big purge movie fan I love
the purge movies the set that the the
they did the three and then they did the
one that was like supposed to be the
prequel and that one was just I like
them all and that one was just not that
it wasn't that good sorry it's all good
but you know what you did you know you
goddamn did you ever see a movie and
you're like hey guys you know you
goddamn did it's all good
I watched it cool 50 please but you know
you watched a movie last night well
Netra name will remain nameless it was
an Oscar nominated movie hey hey dude
you know he got him dead it was bad it
was [ __ ] bad all these must so many
of these movies are bad whatever but
it's all good they keep making them why
even make a movie now just [ __ ] get a
youtube channel you know uh I guess I
don't know I so then I went to Las Vegas
alright went to Las Vegas now when I
went to Las Vegas I got this I got this
oh by the way before I wrap this up my
whole point is Oakland figure out your
[ __ ] dough situation dude figure out
your [ __ ] dough situation I'm a
comedian when I go [ __ ] thirty
minutes on stage I don't I don't say
well guys ran out of jokes I do 30 more
minutes of jokes you're a pizza place
have god damned oh cheese and tomato
sauce and that's it that's it have that
I got jokes okay if I have jokes in
Oakland and I'm then I'm [ __ ] doing
my [ __ ] have dough pizza places alright
so then I got went to Las Vegas got
there
um and I took one of those jet sweet
planes that was like it's like you go up
to the private Airport and they [ __ ]
take you and it's cool and there's a
bunch of other people on the planes but
it's always like guys who are like fake
rich you know cuz if you're real rich
you'd have a private jet but if you're
fake rich like me you'll have a [ __ ]
you'll just take this jet sweet thing
and you'd be like oh I don't have to do
security or TSA you just hop on the
plane by the way how the [ __ ] is that
legal
how long until you think they'd bury
those thing these things these jet sweet
things they got a delta and shit's got
to be like these do Delta's got to be
like the Suge Knight in these
[ __ ] soon so I go on this jet
suite the people were so loud there were
these four dudes that were going from
Oakland to Vegas is probably there for
their you know dude weekend and they
were so loud how are you so there's
always a loud [ __ ] on the planes
dude talk softer in public anyway
whatever it doesn't matter I don't mean
a complain even though I do so I get to
Las Vegas and I'm playing I played the
Mirage uh and boys two men has a
residency there and I've been a fan of
boys to men for boys to men for a while
you know ever since I was a kid and I've
played there and they always do the
eight o'clock show and then I do the ten
o'clock show whenever I go to Vegas I do
it like twice a year and Mirage but they
do it like every Friday or Saturday
where the [ __ ] it is so I got there and
before you know it I'm in the green room
with some of my people just hanging out
knock-knock-knock them them them that up
the guy goes hey I just wanted to come
over and say hey welcome yada yada and I
look and it's one of the [ __ ] boys to
men and I was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me dude no way I'm such a huge
fan of yours and I've been such a huge
fan of yours
for a long time and the guy was like
really and I was like hell yeah and then
the other dude who goes behind the real
recognizable one the one who's the one
who does the one that the the one who
goes [ __ ] begins gula we used to
dream about this every day
get it up man that guy I just dreams a
bad way yeah nobody wants to get it dude
that guy who has the face that looks
like he would just be so nice while
[ __ ] your [ __ ] was like hey man how
does sunglasses on of course do you know
why because it's a time it's a time in
the day or night dude if your boys to
men you're not wearing sunglasses at all
times
you ain't boys to man I'll tell you that
so this guy comes up behind the guy by
the way he came up behind the guy that
already said hi like in the video when
he does the video he comes up behind the
guy and he was like on his dreams a
fadeaway yeah that's how he came up
behind the guy who said he was [ __ ]
welcoming me so I was like is this guy
gonna pull some [ __ ] dum dum dum da
da so I was like dude I'm a huge fan of
yours man he was like oh we're big fans
too and I was like really and he was
like yeah and he goes kick it and the
guy goes dum dum dum da da
I'm kidding that didn't happen but if
that happened I would have pissed my
pants and I would have [ __ ] smiled
the whole time doing it and then while
they were going by I I add up Donna Rojo
and then the guy will be like you know
you come in the guy who just doesn't
even sing by the way that just comes up
and it's just like yeah you've been
coming to the Mirage for quite some time
but you know what you never met us did
you
chum them them that up but just the
night you go meet us chum them them that
Diana and you Joe you know what we got
for you while you perform him you got
some Sun we got some sunglasses for you
and now you are on a Mary honorary
member of boys to men here you go and
then I put them on they go ladies and
gentlemen Chris D'Elia and I go out on
stage and they come out and they're just
like dum dum da da dum dum dum use a
damn about this every day hey no really
I sort of got one time he goes like this
really ha ha so [ __ ] to not do the words
that's so awesome to be so good
how about the guy when when the guy goes
in all the Phillies stakes you can eat
fat they were all rolled their eyes
behind a girl they took the glory with a
kiss
dum dum dum da da because you know the
Billy stay
you could eat like oh he's fat just let
him have it dude yeah can I talk about
Philly steaks in this one no please
it's about Philly fine this is the fine
look when you go [ __ ] them them them
that up just let him go [ __ ] another
Philly's States you can eat or some [ __ ]
when you go buy a yacht yada yada let
him go
with all the Philly states you can eat
slung overdue but now Phil he slammed
them them bad boys them in a BCP BD
discos family never skipped a beat nah
while cooling on sale to jet that bags
pull your friends and know the Phillies
stakes you can eat no no no that's what
they're doing nom nom nom nom nom nom
nom nom nom nom nom nada
Nana hmm we in cheese skates my girl we
used to dream about this every day
another Philly steak city no not now
dude he just keeps going he's got
Tourette's syndrome
he can't that's his thing and I love
Philly steaks you can you eat what if
you had Tourette's syndrome and that was
your tick people are just like hanging
out yeah yeah it's cool all nice are
cool my let's go another Philly steak
city whoa whoa whoa dude what the [ __ ]
that's his tech dude don't don't even
what they'll shame you if you make fun
of it the [ __ ]
that's his tic yeah well what the [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] in life not really he's with
a group called boys to men it kind of
worked out they did a song about Philly
oh when they go oh gonna throw up I
always thought when I was a kid what's
it go back in here we'll go down more
live and what lovin direct from Philly
town runnin Hamblin we can get down we
are ready to roll so now the world but
know what we ma
do it boys cement is the [ __ ] and they
know it dude that's the best part
dude one of the guys had sweat pants on
performing in Vegas so relaxed but still
with the sunglasses dude he sleeps with
them on he's so dope dude they're so
dope they were so cool I want to be in
boys to men dude I'm in boys to men
fifty please
[Music]
Wow man I remember when I was a kid in
high school going through a breakup
really listening to boys to men and
being like god damn they [ __ ] know
don't they and then thinking now about
how they were 15 years younger than me
now that's so funny
talk about [ __ ] dum dum da da god
that's so funny of course one of the
boys to men's name is Shawn you know
Dallas Shawn Nathan and Michael sweat
guys look I love how on the lyrics it
goes doom doom da dum da da dum dum dum
da da da dee da dadadada
but the can really go around Wow Wow
anyway
they were [ __ ] so I went onstage I
talked about boys to men for [ __ ] ten
minutes before I did my act which was
basically I just did what I just did for
you guys so you Welk
so anyway then I went to Connecticut and
I had a show for a college Yukon which
is a legit college big college and it
was cool I actually it was a great show
for me I had a good time and all that
[ __ ] and you know the car the kids
seemed to really like it I said kids but
you know we're all really we're all
young we're all young did we're all
young I'm in that generation okay I'm
young as [ __ ]
hmm and then I got a Google Alert which
I still have on my name which I got to
get off the ship it's so annoying I did
the show was fine made fun of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] there and then going into
my material and did this did the show
didn't regular [ __ ] follow the leader
tour and then this the campus one of the
people on the campus wrote about it and
let me find some stuff here just some of
the stuff that's said on this book
article article while many of his jokes
were offensive or targeted individuals
there seemed to be a defined line he
wouldn't cross for laughs I guess I
don't know I mean I wouldn't consider
that by myself but even though when even
when he did go a little too far his
jokes were still well-received whatever
yada yada um hold on a second
daliyah's best joke this is the [ __ ]
there's just like what are you doing
here why you ranking jokes um let me go
to the part that I saw though some kid
they interviewed a kid I thought it was
really funny I don't usually go for
comedy but I thought this was really
cool okay cool thanks but um oh here we
go one of of his jokes the worst
received one was about how I'm not gonna
say it cuz you should come see it anyway
the worst received one the shock noise
the shocked noise that colored most that
I can own that part echo the shock noise
echoed across the audience which while
not entirely uncommon in the LEAs show
lacked all the laughter it had in the
prior instances you know what's funny is
that's not a joke that part that's the
set up the thing that the referencing is
the setup to the joke that by the way
after that after that part of my act I
talked about how sometimes people get
offended
and this prompted him it says this
prompted him to jump into his speech
about how most comedians don't do
college get night that didn't say that I
said a lot of comedians won't do to
colleges because college students get
offended really easily I said he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about that and that he would
have wouldn't apologize yeah right and
so that's what I did so what they didn't
[ __ ] add this is so funny because
this is where we're at was that got a
huge applause break so the they're
saying the worst of the worst received
joke which was not a joke it was the
setup to the joke which never gets a
laugh because it's not a joke so this
person like doesn't get what a setup or
a punchline is fine that end of that
joke got a huge laugh so here's the
thing that's [ __ ] crazy too the jokes
not offensive it's just not an offensive
joke it's a literally a made-up thing
that has never happened and that I just
make up and so it's not offensive
because didn't happen anyone so so this
is why comedians don't want to play
colleges but it's funny because everyone
in the crowd laughed and this person
wrote this and this was the person that
didn't like that joke so they are
writing this so now it seems like people
didn't like that part which is not true
but this is a this is this is what's
[ __ ] up is that it's I mean this is
kind of a version of virtuous signaling
because like you you're this person's
the people will then read this and be
like oh he can't say that kind of stuff
thanks for speaking out or whatever and
it's like you're the this kind of time
we live in the people who say you can't
say that because it hurts people's
feelings or you can't say that because
it's offensive are perceived as the good
guys so this person writes this
subconsciously or consciously because it
makes them feel like a good guy
because then other people will be like
ah good to stand up for that even though
it's so unnecessary because it's a
comedy show the people who write this
are the minority though but it's the
people who write this that write this
which means this is the [ __ ] that's
being written which means this is the
[ __ ] that's being read and this 100%
this kind of thing is why Trump got
elected so it's all good but that's what
happened um because I was at the show do
you know why it's my show I was on the
stage everyone laughed and had a good
time there were no parts that were
touch-and-go or weird ah now this person
on this blog is said in for the show was
funny they didn't say the show was not
good they they said you know it was a
good show it was fun it was just like it
I just thought it was it was funny how
interesting how he still had to pick
that kind of a thing because it was like
the college thing to do she's so [ __ ]
interesting this [ __ ] that's going on in
the world these the the the the the the
the they're not the majority who feel
this way but because they're the people
who write about it it makes it seem that
way and then the people who shame like
this isn't one of those things as it was
nothing but like if somebody saw that
and decided to shame me for it and then
it piled on I mean it's nothing but and
they're piled on and it became a thing
it would seem like my life was over but
it's not because these people are just
they're few and far in between but
they're the people who write about it
because everyone who liked it was
everyone in the audience I was there
there was one or two people that thought
this and that's the person who writes
the article because they want to seem
like a good guy
and that's the [ __ ] problem they're
not a good guy they're just doing neck
- nothing the whole idea if comedy isn't
offensive to anyone it's not comedy it's
offensive all jokes are offensive to
somebody otherwise it's not funny
that's it so thanks for saying the show
is good and funny but if you think that
that joke is offensive what do you get
into the real [ __ ] world dude
where do you get out of college and get
to a place where do you where do you
leave college and get to anywhere you're
gonna cry a lot okay nobody tell me
nothing softie please no more blue apron
dude I eat blue apron so much I'm gonna
turn into a blue apron I swear I love
this this food it's amazing
dude you could just get the food
delivered to you and it shows up you
make the food step by step instructions
and it's so easy they have the best
ingredients I am Telling You I eat it I
love I have yet to have a bad move um a
meal and I eat it all the time and I
love it
even stuff that I didn't think I'd liked
blue apron figured out a way to involve
me to make me like it the hardest part
of meal prep is deciding what to cook
with blue apron that's where the fun
comes in they helped me discover my
inner chef and learn new recipes and
techniques and now guess what love
cooking my babies blue apron has exposed
me to delicious recipes I would never
have thought to try I'm well I'm I'm
more cultured now because a blue apron
I'm a better person my palate is more
sophisticated they make it they make
cooking at home a sustainable part of my
weekly routine
I got a hectic schedule the way from III
they made it easier I go out to eat too
much but not with blue apron it helps me
and it's cheaper - I got a time I got
time to cook a delicious wholesome meal
instead of relying on takeout to start
making delicious brag worthy meals at
home without the hassle of try blue
apron check out this week's menu and get
sixty dollars off or socks deed
when you visit blue apron calm /
Congrats that's blue apron dot-com /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
calm now listen I get stressed my hair
lines a little thinner than it was 10
years ago
stress is a worldwide epidemic we're
working long longer hours were inundated
with a constant news cycle and were more
connected than ever before and we're not
even supposed to be we're humans humans
aren't equipped to deal with that but
stress is a part of life now it can be
very it can very easily affect our
overall well-being it happens all the
time happens to me my babies that's
where we're partnering with calm the
number one app to help you reduce your
anxiety and stress and to help you sleep
better now I put the calm act upon guess
what happened more than 40 million
people around the world have downloaded
it if you go to calm calm / Congrats
you'll get 25 percent off a comp
premiums subscription which includes
guided meditations on issues like
anxiety stress and focus including a
brand new meditation each day they even
have soothing music and more it's they
have sleep stories it's really great go
in and browse around right now Congrats
listeners get 25% off a comprar Miam
subscription at Kham Kham / Congrats
that CA LM dot-com / Congrats
get unlimited access to all of coms
content today at calm calm / Congrats
get calm and stop stressing
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app America's favorite alternative
to balling up some bills and throwing
them at people you owe money so that's
where I went this weekend and that's
what's up haven't
okay let me delete this stuff here how
about this end game [ __ ] that's going on
this movie is just [ __ ] cleaning up
we all thought it would no I didn't see
it yet and want to go probably gonna go
tonight
take the chica and want to want to go
tonight it's over three hours long like
it's a goddamn movie about [ __ ] the
Gettysburg Address or some [ __ ] and they
got to wrap up a lot of stuff you know
why four billion characters do you know
why they got to wrap up a lot you know
why the story you know why it's over
three hours long got to wrap up each
[ __ ] arc for three billion characters
hey ant-man is in it
hey ant-man is in it hey hey Marvel you
know how you're making too many movies
do you know how you know you're making
too many movies ant-man hey Marvel you
know how you're you know how you know
you're making too many movies too many
blue characters okay I mean Jesus dude
every [ __ ] tenth guys blue forty
forty forty character for the characters
in the movies could forevermore blow
you'll make my dog shut up dude will you
[ __ ] open the door Tony shut the [ __ ]
up there barking and [ __ ] so annoying uh
can you even hear it I wonder hey
butters shut the [ __ ] up
they're good that worked that worked
daddy came through yelled at the [ __ ]
babies it's all good the [ __ ] shut up
they know what's up dude
they stopped I don't know if you could
hear it but they stopped they were like
fifty please no more dude so let me talk
to you about this endgame [ __ ] man first
of all if if you're uh if you're
the kind of pert now let me actually
start this by saying I don't give a [ __ ]
if somebody suppose a movie for me it
doesn't matter to me I don't care I
don't watch a movie because of what
happens as a matter of fact I think if
you're a move if you're a guy who goes
to a movie to see what happens you're
kind of an idiot I see a movie to watch
how what happens okay you see a movie to
see how it happens how they make the
movie this story how it unfolds okay if
you're going to a movie to see what
happens
you are [ __ ] to come don't [ __ ] to
come [ __ ] because it feels good the
whole time and it's lovemaking you're
doing it to bust a nut
you bad purse you're going to see
endgame because you want to see what
happens
you bad purse you bad movie goer it's
free conch go if you want to but you
know deep inside you bad purse also
Marvel ant-man you go watch a movie to
see how it all unfolds otherwise yeah
yes huh all right now I don't give a
[ __ ] somebody tells me ant-man
dies flying up Thanos ass he suffocates
okay still go see the movie right
everyone saw Titanic you know how that
goddamn [ __ ] ends you go see it because
you want to see the story all right
there that's it glad we figured that out
all right now god I'm such a [ __ ] so so
now set saying that okay on the other
end of that if you're the kind of person
that thinks it's funny or just the kind
of [ __ ] that spoils a movie you're a
real special kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I don't care if you do it for me
personally but if you do that for other
people
you're a [ __ ] you are a supreme
[ __ ] like that guy who tweeted it I
don't know I'm not gonna say what he
tweeted because
heed this I think this football player I
wrote like damn saw Avengers can't
believe yada yada this happened like
such an [ __ ] such a find out who that
was the guy who spoiled the end game the
football player but such an [ __ ] like
[ __ ] you guy people wait in line for the
money
how about the guy who actually this
happened on on I tweeted about it go to
my Twitter for the article I just
googled Twitter that's how I get on on
Twitter like a [ __ ] idiot like a dad
I don't even know password of course not
it not it not it nobody know it's all
good anyway running back
LeSean McCoy lashauwn Twitter is the
Twitter nation is taking a dim view of
that I fell Super Start on his shady
okay he has hundreds of thousands of
followers I guess and he repeatedly
revealed the biggest secret of the
Avengers endgame dude you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] you um you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] what's his name LeSean
McCoy like what a dick and then didn't
delete it like you're just ruining
people's [ __ ] joy what imagine being
a [ __ ] [ __ ] like that for real
this is just ruining people's joy for no
[ __ ] reason but the thing that what I
thought was so funny was how like Marvel
and all of the movie stars were tweeting
hashtag don't spoil the end game like
number one that's not going to help in
in any way number two it's
absolutely gonna make it worse will you
tell somebody not to do something
especially the world a few people are
gonna do it like don't spoil the end
game like everyone knows not to spoil
the movie or you're an [ __ ] but they
still gonna do it and if you say don't
do it those [ __ ] are gonna be like
well [ __ ] them they can't control me cuz
they had bad childhoods cuz your dad
died early your dad died early you're
telling me not to oh you're not you're
telling me not to spoil the end game
well guess what my dad died early so
this is what happens but you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Shawn look Kroy
you're [ __ ] you're the worst flavor
of Lucroy that's what you are you're
that [ __ ] Pamplemousse [ __ ] and I
know [ __ ] one fire likes to
Pamplemousse but I'll tell you right now
Pamplemousse Lacroix can go [ __ ] itself
dude call it what is it grapefruit call
it grapefruit dude what kind of [ __ ]
yep of course it is
tangerines the worst wand fire loves
tangerine Ivan gets rid of loves
tangerine and it's the worst
Pamplemousse the worst tangerine the
worst Kiwi flavor the [ __ ] out of here
dude get out like it no even we all
don't like it in here
Ivan get rid of anyone fire our like get
the [ __ ] out of town tangerine
Pamplemousse out Kiwi lime out lime
tastes like cleaning fluid still good
lemon tastes like cleaning fluid still
good the regular time crying got it
right here still good the worst kind
lashauwn Lacroix you're a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] for ruining the end game for a
bunch of kids dude [ __ ] you also here's
the other thing how about the guy that
was outside of the Avengers people
waiting allowed to see it and he would
swear there's an article I tweeted about
I can't log into my Twitter but he was
he was he was yelling about it about
what happens and people beat the [ __ ]
out of him you got beaten the [ __ ] out
of and that definitely happened in an
Asian country for sure that's so Asian
to happen so Avengers endgame spoiler
man beaten outside Hong Kong cinema
there you go a man who obviously didn't
get the memo on Avengers that game or
chose to ignore it was beaten outside a
Hong Kong cinema for shouting out
spoilers to fans waiting in line to see
the film dude that guy if I saw that guy
got
here's the thing man I'm never a
proponent for p-ting people getting beat
up you know I think so it's like dude do
you do you think something I go back and
forth on do some people need to get
their ass kicked I'm like you know maybe
but also nah we could always work it out
if you just [ __ ] use your words you
idiot you know but this guy it's like
people should we should really shouldn't
be beating people up but hey guy who did
this work with us try and help us out
trying to help us out so we don't have
to beat this [ __ ] at anybody are you
gonna spoil the end game in line at end
game hey man your nose is gonna get all
bloody someone's gonna do a [ __ ]
roundhouse kick on you how about that
friend and you end and that's the end of
your game I'll tell you that much
dude well I mean dude like what do you
think was gonna happen these first of
all the guys were in law Allina end game
are [ __ ] the biggest dorks on the
planet cuz they're first in line right
wait a week hey dark Oh a toe week but
they care cuz they don't want to get
spoiled they don't want to get spoiled
so they wait in line and then you're out
there [ __ ] prancing the hollering
about how who dies or whatever the [ __ ]
in the movie
these dorks are like I've never fired at
anybody in my life just to make them
alive how you'd [ __ ] do this super
thin Ian power or whatever the [ __ ]
super sibian power sibian the [ __ ]
thing that get you get [ __ ] your
vagina for super therian power and then
they all [ __ ] try to do actual karate
because they're dorks and don't know how
to fight you know how about the guy that
goes I guess looking man couldn't kills
you you ever see that what was it like
vine with a guy they go wow and they go
oh [ __ ] man I almost killed you overall
you know which one I'm talking about
where the guy walks in the kitchen and
they're like rawr and he goes oh [ __ ]
and could almost killed you and any
[ __ ] moves his hair at his face [ __ ]
you didn't almost kill someone if you
almost moved your if you'd move your
hair out of your face afterwards
fighting is fighting it's not styling
your hair please father no more fighting
is crazy I still can't believe that
there's a UFC my buddy did it Brendan
Schaub did UFC four [ __ ] years
knocked people out and got knocked out
that's crazy
that's insane I mean did the two hardest
things that and then stand up after this
he's gonna try and be a brain surgeon
heart transplant guy doctor um it's
gonna be a doctor for stress management
and [ __ ] 50-cents gonna have to send
somebody to go see him please fifteen no
more so so yeah dude if I was in the UFC
by the way why isn't anybody doing it
let me i actually know why nobody's
doing this but i'm still asking the
question why isn't anybody doing this
dude there needs to be as a UFC guy who
comes up through the ranks who is super
calm and acts like a serial killer that
would be the [ __ ]
that's who that's out look there's a
reason why I'm not a UFC fighter but if
I was dude I would be walking in I would
have button up all the way to the top
slicked to the side hair by a comb and I
would sit down and I would talk like
they'd be like what do you think for
your next fight against [ __ ] cage him
a cage dude and I would be like it's
interesting you ask that question I'm
going to demolish him and they'd be like
whoa well yeah I'm okay well the thing
is why is there nobody that says like
the thing that's interesting about
fighting is that there's only one winner
and one loser even if there's a tie
there's either a tiebreaker or they look
at the other points I'm going to end my
opponent and if I don't end him
physically
I'm going to end him mentally afterwards
by shaming him publicly and I'm going to
find him and I'm going to kill him oh
why is there nobody that does that hello
audience I'm here at the wayon weigh me
I guarantee I weigh as much as a as much
as I have to because I have steadfast
determination when it comes to this
stuff and any time the other guy says
something about him like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kick your [ __ ] ass he just
goes you make me laugh big boy
are you kidding me UFC Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam superimpose graphics pam pam
pam pam pam pam i'm pay people more
eyeballs pam pam pam pam pump pumping
I'll rip it the baby Bam Bam Bam I'm
gonna kick that motherfucker's ass that
makes me laugh I'm going to eat you in
the cage big boy with glasses just to
the side cocked you're nothing I hope
you don't give me your back I'm going to
[ __ ] your anus if that's what happens
pam pam pam pam pam pam a baby a baby
between remember Pam please fifty please
fifty them them them that up them them
them that up dude are you kidding me why
is nobody doing that the only guy who
comes close to doing that is you and
McGregor Conor McGregor and it's a it's
not even close dude
it's not even close I'm your [ __ ]
daddy that was the closest he came tell
him Ami's [ __ ] daddy
no not good enough dude you're a great
you're great entertainment why you're
[ __ ] Muhammad Ali of the now but come
on bro get a guy out there that doesn't
move that's just sitting there I can't
wait for this fight this nut doesn't
look at anybody just like this I can't
wait for this fight do you think she's
going to beat me but I'm going to [ __ ]
I'm going to [ __ ] his anus in' and [ __ ]
him up these pocket protectors and [ __ ]
that's the best UFC guy that's it why is
nobody pretending they're the serial
killer version of that [ __ ] I'm hot yes
[ __ ] yes oh yes do it it's 85 degrees in
here because of the lights yes I love
being a [ __ ] so hot dude sitting in a
room for no reason not even doing
anything no matter what you're shooting
you get hot cuz the lights
yes I do the stand-up shows it's always
hot on stage yes I do [ __ ] I shoot
for you it's always hot because all the
lights and it's a big production that's
in my podcast room sitting down just
talking is it too hot yes [ __ ] yes I
want being too hot dude
am i sweating too much yes [ __ ] yeah
dude is it like I'm playing baseball yes
so annoying no matter what the [ __ ] you
shoot you got until I got right now I
got [ __ ] just just cascading I got a
waterfall of sweat just cascading down
my [ __ ] triple black diamond AB
course you want to do a tricky ski
course dude try skiing down my [ __ ]
tummy see if you don't hyperextend your
knees
[ __ ] yeah I'd do it too hot baby it's
too hot you're gonna [ __ ] stagecoach
imagine going to stagecoach I've got my
horses in the bag I'm gonna tell me
nothing stagecoach line up let's just
look at it so we can get all pissed
let's look at this stagecoach line up
here we go
look right I'll go up to the photo [ __ ]
oh my god this photo of Luke Bryan Luke
what is it Luke Bryan Bryant Luke Bryan
two first names can't [ __ ] can't do
that to you kid
so [ __ ] this photo dude looka go up to
it it looks like he's going oh god that
guy couldn't look more like he's from
[ __ ] Ventura California he's got a
song that's called doing my thang yeah
it's anything these are the people these
are the people in the [ __ ] thing
listen to these names Luke Bryan Cole
Swindell Swindell Kane Brown I mean
these names dude Luke Bryan Cole
Swindell came Brown Bret Michaels Scotty
McCreery Russell dickerson are you
[ __ ] kidding me these names Devon
Dawson Joe Diffie Cody Johnson
Tyler rich dude this is amazing
Brandon Leigh Dan Tyminski that's the
old man that doesn't kind of go Ashley
Monroe John Langston Carlton Anderson
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me these names
this is like the white version of
[ __ ] LaShawn Lacroix Sam hunt his
voice is just smooth as butter ha Sam
hunt Luke Combs Lynyrd Skynyrd Michael
Ray Jesse James Decker
Travis Denning whiskey Myers hey guy
do you own a pair of boots
Aubrey Sellars I mean every one of these
even Rachel why Mac like wha Mac is such
a [ __ ] country Charlie Crockett dude
are you [ __ ] kidding me
Crockett these are these names are so
country I forgot about them
Jason Aldean Old Dominion Lauren Elena
wow this is hilarious dude Tom Jones
Jordan Davis Danielle Bradbury mark
Chesnutt whitey Morgan Mitchel Tenpenny
oh go [ __ ] yourself dude oh go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] your country ass dude
are you kidding me dude
Mitchell Tenpenny go [ __ ] yourself man
Jimmy Allen Terry Clark
Parker Millsap Abbi Anderson alright you
know what dude
Ruby boots are you [ __ ] kidding me
dude look at this
featuring Guy Fieri stagecoach
smokehouse hey dude [ __ ] straight-up
powder would go to this thing and be
like oh this is too white are you
[ __ ] me Irish people [ __ ] from
Ireland who can't go out in the Sun read
this lineup and they get a tan this is
on real Nicky Lane's stage top stage
stop marketplace dude Nicky lanes stage
stop marketplace unbelievable all these
names Wow
[ __ ] powder if that was a name on
this
if white [ __ ] head powder was a name on
this lineup it would be the fourth
whitest name do you know why
Ruby boots whiskey Meyers and Mitchell
Tenpenny Mitchell Tenpenny sounds like a
[ __ ] fake Batman villain real name
like he's Mitchell Tenpenny by day but
by night he's dr. giggles every one of
these names deserve a dude stagecoach
bro come on man go home [ __ ] it man
they make it money you can't fault them
love when people making money love when
people get [ __ ] bags they're all part
of the bags unit that's crazy dude Wow
okay nobody tell me nothing I can tell
me nothing why is he not on it little
nas ex and got the horses in the bag and
the horses in the tragg and the horses
in the rag and the horses and the brag
if that song was that it still have it
still be a big hit the same amount of
hits all right let's do uh
misconnections
where we going from misconnections this
week the Inland Empire which I have a
feeling is going to be real dirty when
you get to the Inland Empire it's real
[ __ ] dirty man Inland Empire is it
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] Wow okay well
starting off with a bang I would love to
watch someone suck on it so good this
guy should write a book huh really great
sentence dude I would love to watch
someone suck on it so good the fact that
he added so good is great I have like
first of all the body of this starts
with a comma hey guy no sentence starts
with a comma
I have like two hours I'm by Johnson and
Palmdale Road it's throbbing so so good
I even get some balm Tina to share even
got some balm Tina to share my dick is
going to explode oh well do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
hey dude I even got some bum Tina to
share what a great aside dude my [ __ ]
gonna explode need want to suck it so so
good however I haven't got some balm
Tina to share Wow Inland Empire up to no
good
what do we got out what else we got here
okay well so sad well the subject of
this one is exes sad let's see if the
body changes the changes what it means
looking for dad
the body is student here looking for dad
with large tool okay it changed not
really from a [ __ ] fatherless home
anymore
need help with school project email
fillet what student here looking for dad
with large tool definitely section why
this thing bounces back and forth from
sexual to not sexual within sentences
looking for dad student here looking for
dad with large to look looking for dad
not sexual student here looking for
looking for dad with large tool so
sexual need help with school project not
sexual anymore the guy went Bam Bam Bam
Bam email for details and number do not
contact me once ELISA services or offers
do it soon you're looking for dad with
large tool need to have a school project
want to [ __ ] in the ass psyche need help
with a paper that's basically what he's
saying alright want to suck you off
psyche need to need someone to help me
even [ __ ] lay my graph out Wow oh
this one's sad start sad - it really is
a boring day so far anyone want to chat
about anything Inland Empire and then
the body is let me know if you're
interested do not contact me on servers
or offers hey guy just get Twitter just
start tweeting people between you
that's a real weird one that's an odd
non-sexual one have a feeling it's
sexual though have a feeling if a girl
or a guy or whatever he's into we wrote
back
hey mint macaques gonna explode he be
look - sounds interesting let's get back
to her see what's going on I'm looking
for a vanilla ice cream I have a G H
available what's G H do you know I'm
hosting in my place looking to eat your
vanilla creamy ice cream Oh God you know
I have a G H ready clean inside and
outside G H glory hole good house good
half God be glory hole yeah I'm looking
for a vanilla ice cream I have a glory
hole available Jesus Christ that's like
a [ __ ] real thing hey guy
just say it anybody want to stick their
[ __ ] in a hole do not contact me with
unsolicited services are offered offers
okay Wow how about glory holes dude what
hey dude so trustworthy dude you're
gonna stick your most vulnerable part of
your body in a random hole so
trustworthy what if the person on the
other side roughs you up what if the
person on the other side is the opposite
sex of what you're into what if the
person on the other side bites your dick
off
trustworthy I'll tell you what man if
someone has ever used a glory hole ever
even once that's a person you tell a
secret to that person is a trustworthy
[ __ ] oh wow well that's good huh
we're good please 50 no more
50 dude man so download the so download
the cash up for free on the App Store or
Google Play market it's free
I'll wait I need that back
download the crystal Lea app - you can
you can go to my app and see the podcast
before you see anybody before you see it
before anyone else sees it you know what
that sentence is supposed to be
we've got merch you can go get your
dance shirts or this free conch or just
support congratulations pockets by
keeping the getting the congratulations
parka shirt we also have the do not
contact me with unsolicited services are
all for shirt which is my favorite one
that's my favorite one we're coming
we're coming to Edmond Edmonton Victoria
BC Memphis Tennessee Chattanooga
Tennessee and Knoxville Tennessee I've
got some new dates added to San Jose
Chicago Illinois all added shows here
and we'll see you this weekend des
Moines and where else
Fargo Wells Fargo North Dakota Wells
Fargo North Dakota Fargo North Dakota
Edmond with Sioux Falls South Dakota
never been either one of those business
and Des Moines Iowa very cool that two
shows a clinic
bags baby and remember dude you have a
problem with 50 just text them thanks
guys
[Music]